the miami dolphins have been searching
and searching and searching some more
for a starting quarterback who would
have the franchise caliber attached to
his name since dan marino retired after
the 1999 season 16 in all and oh boy not
good and now we don't know what the plan
is they have finally given up on ryan
tannehill who had seven years to prove
that he could be a franchise quarterback
now he's out ryan fitzpatrick is in with
a two-year contract reported base value
of 11 million dollars that is peanuts as
starting quarterback contracts go but we
don't even know whether he's going to be
the starting quarterback chris he may be
the placeholder for whoever they end up
with in the draft and they had to sign
somebody they had to have somebody who
was the plausible starter so it isn't
obvious going into the draft that
they're going to draft a quarterback
because then at number 13 they're going
to get leapfrogged by somebody for the
quarterback that they want so smart move
to have fitzpatrick smart move to have a
guy who has played well
he gets criticized a lot but my god
early last year he was spectacular and
he's better than whatever other options
they had on the roster so now they have
a bird in the hand and we'll see what
they do on draft day yeah that's right i
mean there wasn't a lot of options out
there in free agency once city bret
teddy bridgewater said no uh we knew
they weren't going to bring back ryan
tannehill so you know to what you're
saying yes i think it was a very smart
decision to bring a guy in like ryan
fitzpatrick gives them some wiggle room
i mean they are at number 13 in the nfl
draft certainly can be in prime position
to get one of these quarterbacks maybe
not kyla murray they're gonna have to
make moves if they want to get kyla
murray and get up to the first second
third pick probably but you know does it
dwayne haskins does a drew lock are they
around a 13. i think there's a good
chance i wouldn't have said that a few
weeks ago but i think as i sort through
the draft more and more
there is a good chance that i think one
of those two might be on the board
jacksonville at seven i don't think
they're gonna be drafting a quarterback
there this year it's really about the
giants it's six right now as the team
that's really the obvious team that
might be in the quarterback conversation
and i don't think there's any guarantee
they'll take a quarterback at six so uh
the dolphins yes you get this because
you got a guy okay we got our starting
quarterback now they can figure out what
they want to do with the quarterback
situation going forward into their
future
and the thing with the ryan tannehill
deal
look i thought they were just going to
cut him and and they didn't need to keep
him around there's no guaranteed money
in his deal as it stood before friday
but they found somebody who would take
him in trade
but that team wanted the dolphins to pay
part of his salary even though the
dolphins were on the hook for nothing
guaranteed so ultimately what the
dolphins did they dumped ryan tannehill
and they bought a fourth-round pick in
2020 for five million dollars because
they're paying five million dollars of
ryan tannehill's new salary of seven
million fully guaranteed the titans get
a backup quarterback for two million
dollars and ryan tannehill better than
blaine gabbert they were going to play
gab pay gabbert a million and a half
right i'll pay 2 million to tannehill
because if tannehill's healthy he's not
horrible he's actually pretty good the
problem is he can't stay healthy right
but you only need him to be healthy one
or two games in the full year and think
about it if they had a better backup
last year chris when marcus mariota
missed a couple of games they're a
playoff team they're a contending team
exactly right mike i'll sit here and say
i'm not so sure ryan tannehill's not
better than marcus mariota they're very
similar so it makes sense for tennessee
to get a guy like tannehill to be the
backup quarterback they're both very
good athletes who play quarterback
that's what i would say about the two
guys i mean can run they can do the read
option the bootlegs play action passes
all that stuff but tannenhill i think is
probably a more gifted passer and
thrower than marcus mariota but either
way it was a smart move by john robinson
the gm of the tennessee titans to get a
quarterback that's similar skill set to
a mariota if he does go down the offense
doesn't miss a beat you don't have to
change things around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports